[Musik]
leute ich sitze zusammen mit sebastian
wir haben es uns gemütlich gemacht vor
dem computer denn wir gucken uns jetzt
zusammen eine decke im strato love
compilation an ich muss nicht sagen ich
finde ja ich bin ungefähr ein prozent
von allen sachen enthält die lustig sein
sollen lust aber deb-teams kriegen mich
schon das ein oder andere mal dass ich
richtig lachen musste ich weiß nicht
dass diese diese komme die sachen so
finde ich einfach alle nicht lustig aber
ich glaube heute könnte es was wäre ich
werde das ganze glaube ich relativ ernst
angehen also wirklich versuchen nicht
zulassen installiert ist das ganz
computer teilt der macht das immer und
diese videos sind teilweise richtig der
aber deshalb einfach mit humor nehmen
ich würde sagen die lage nicht
grundlegend los 321 co
[Musik]
leute ihr seht schon in welche richtung
das geht es sind einfach richtig
abgewickelt man kann es nicht anders
beschreiben es ist nicht so dieses
dieses instrument comedy level lustig
sondern es ist tatsächlich lustig finde
ich ohne das für mich eine ganz neue
erfahrung wie viele toiletten dass man
einen kanal gemacht wo ich mir den arsch
ab gelacht habe außerdem ja sowas einen
erfolg geglaubt da hatten die lustig er
kann hier noch mal so schön des rings
[Musik]
neuer beisitzer ist ja hier schon direkt
umgebracht
das ist bitter
[Musik]
jetzt hieß es
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt liegt im hintergrund kann man hier
mal die konversation hatte das soll so
bot er wahrscheinlich seine
amerikanische grenze mexikaner aber zeit
[Musik]
wird es da weiter
das ist ja so sinnlos wie ging der seite
nun selbst auch blasen das tut
wahrscheinlich innen drin so die länger
festhalten die ermittler so auf klopfen
das ist von zwölfter vierter 2080
wahrheit wahrscheinlich über juling kit
und vorteile ergeben gerade
[Musik]
wer diesen standort computern machen so
bearbeitet die beine von seinem stillen
bild und bestehende bild so dass sich
die beiden bewegen
wo haben sie das wasser kleines kind
operation die pistole zurück
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ganz kurz zuvor gesagt falls sie dass
sie lacht das ist blickt übrigen gnade
der nimmt sich auch selbst also jetzt
auch selbst ein kuvert sei jetzt ein
comedian rettet der spielt kann sich
somit
wir warten immer auf twitter ansagen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
man muss immer dass so etwas erklären
was wichtiger das ist halt das eigene
werbung irgendwann erkannte an dass
andere szene aus gta 5 in der stadt von
gta 5 gibt es auch für diese stelle wo
er das sagt und klasse der kombination
wo ich glaube jetzt einfach nur jemand
der seine augen so raus toppen kann und
der das gemacht hat so stehen gesetzt da
schlafen
es sieht ganz anders aus das ist geil
die date up hätte bereiten sich so
überlegt dass er jetzt fährt
diese decken da gibt es das fest also
das kann ich
[Musik]
die der presse
für verfüttern
[Applaus]
das kennt jeder war früher von immer
darauf warten besser screen saver so die
ecke vom bild trifft es kann natürlich
die jüngsten von euch gar nicht in
deutschland schon als sie dann immer so
von ecke zu ecke gehabt und das hat nie
von ecke zu ecke bereit
[Musik]
was war da die musik so liebe hass der
tufa wenn wir irgendwas mir
[Musik]
wie lange hat in der luft denn die wirte
krank das war krank das verkrampfte alt
ich würde auch sagen das war fertige
video ich muss auf jeden fall ein paar
sachen das kenne ich so gar nicht von
mir war ziemlich lustig sonst schafft
das eigentlich neue youtube kacke
highlight der reifen des anhängers
dann will ich sagen sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen bis dahin tschüss rief
[Gelächter]